la aprobación fue rotunda cabe destacar
que 9 de los 87 parlamentarios que
componen la asamblea legislativa de el
salvador no participaron de esta sesión
de plenaria extraordinaria en la cual se
aprobó por mayoría con 67 votos a favor
la prórroga por otros 30 días calendario
del estado de excepción la iniciativa
del presidente en allí bukle en su
denominada guerra contra las pandillas
durante esta sesión plenaria
extraordinaria se evidenció también la
voz de los diputados opositores que
denunciaron que durante el estado de
excepción han ocurrido vejámenes
violaciones de derechos humanos
detenciones arbitrarias de personas que
solamente por tener tatuajes alusivos a
las bandas criminales pero que no
pertenecerían a las mismas podrían
llegar a ser judicial izados entre 30 y
45 años de cárcel así como denunciaron
la muerte de cuatro pandilleros en
estado de arresto recordemos que el
pasado 27 de marzo fue esta misma
asamblea la que aprobó un primer tiempo
periodo de estado de excepción luego de
que el salvador país centroamericano
sufriera una sus peores olas de
violencia cuando en tres días ocurrieron
más de 80 homicidios que se le
atribuyeron a estas bandas criminales a
las maras y de acuerdo con el propio
presidente del salvador nadie bukele de
no haberse logrado esta prórroga del
estado de excepción se correría el
riesgo de que más de la mitad de los
pandilleros que todavía permanecen
libres generen una nueva ola de
violencia en el país centroamericano